[Music]
do you guys ever chill in your house
thinking about what the hell you're
gonna do when all of this is over yeah
yeah I think about that a lot oh I can't
wait dude the first thing I'm gonna do
is eat at a restaurant yeah what
restaurant where are you going what I
want to copy I want to do sushi yeah
yeah I want to do all like I had a
routine going on before this so in the
morning I will go and get some
Vietnamese food with my coffee I've been
doing that at home trying to replicate
it but I have my go-to restaurant and
then after that I would have sushi for
lunch and for dinner I don't know what
I'm gonna do yet you know I kind of go
last minute it might be Chinese food it
might be mmm it's gotta be things that I
can't cook we gotta do it you can order
dim sum it's the experience I miss like
cream bar qyx oh you could get it to go
no it's not the same meal like ijk dim
sum or a JK dinner and then plus me
invited plus yes plus me to have you
what if you order you're doing something
like a bunch of like ten different
orders ten minutes apart so it just
keeps arriving you're slowly so no you
exactly the same though this ring your
doorbell oh look another lady whoa
future that's nice oh you know future
have you guys been seeing the robots
going around LA delivering food and [ __ ]
no yeah so my friends who live in like
downtown they've been sending pictures
and videos it's like Target has a robot
you ordered a target it'll be like this
like this cart that's sealed up it'll
drive all the way to your house and
deliver stuff on the streets yeah it
goes on the sidewalk in downtown minute
vandalised yeah so the homeless people
don't take try to steal from you I think
it's locked up inside just like a code
and stuff and then uh but like yeah I've
seen online they talk I mean
conversation it
it's just like [ __ ] open me if you
live in a loft or an apartment in
downtown doesn't know how to get inside
past the doorman into the elevator press
the button is how the arm that sticks
out like wall-e wait so how do they even
know when they're like they're the
package is there from your phone it's
like how Tesla knows how to drive like
the car knows how to like oh I was
thinking like they're dropping it off
when you're not home like Amazon's oh no
I think you're at homes everyone at home
right now they're like oh a nice ship I
can't go to Target that's true
so a robot comes this seems I don't know
I imagine a future where like we're
walking around inside or well there'll
be like 20 robots it's bad I don't want
that so cool you get tired you sit on
one of them you know yeah but then what
if they start thinking about [ __ ] yeah
no see I'm on own with you on that I
don't trust that robot to the Future I
mean they're cool but like you walk
you're at the beginning of waling right
now yeah what happened to all he is
human humankind was met with some sort
of devastating thing they had to leave
Earth right and they all just had to
stay behind screens sit and just
automate everything about their land
that is [ __ ] happening right now the
only thing that's different is we're not
leaving the earth that's dope I want to
do that I also want to leave the earth
both of those things so imagine imagine
we all get fat right yeah that's a new
normal and then now you start seeing
attraction and nobody's like shaming
anyone nobody's worrying about so it's
boring it's bug there's some fat girls
that are hot and wall-e everyone looks
hella entertain though think about it I
like that I like that job that's like if
you if you get bored they're not hot
then there's a bunch of hot people I'm
just saying it's boring without drama
I need drama in my life why I think
that's why I'm enjoyed quarantined
no lemons don't yell at them or anything
I
that I want and there's no fighting
there is conflict as you're cooking make
if you said so there might be drama I
like some oil splashes on your dick or
something
well I cut my thumb a couple - that's
dramatic yeah well if that's what you
consider drama I cut my hand everyday
drama every day more than the real drama
that exists in the world I'd be seeing
people online posting they're like so
like with any issue they're like if you
do this I'm a block you I'm I'll follow
you I'm like who are you like to post
that but then someone's like if I see
you out at a park or this time a block
you and follow you do you need to be
like self isolating and then they get
out and they're like but my mental
health I need to get out there and eat
breather but it's like different for
that everyone wants drama and they
started creating online I don't mean
that kind of drama I like happy drama
you're happy drunk cutting my beer it's
better than [ __ ] the [ __ ] fighting
with the girlfriend all the time yeah
don't got my boy right but that's much
better than fighting all [ __ ] day in
the house Oh God is it better
we have someone though huh you have
someone at least well I don't know cuz I
don't feel lonely you're trying to make
him feel oh do you still talk to
yourself I talked to myself regardless
more more that's what I said that the
time hasn't nothing has changed from you
think he's talking to you right now but
he's actually talking to himself he
thinks you're a figment of his
imagination - you're not hearing me
yeah none of us are here right I want
all of the cameras in Joe's house I do
too I want it I want Joe to become a
billionaire like [ __ ] fat rich - he's
gonna buy it because it's for my
personal entertainment and then he
should have my own show yeah they're
keeping up with the kardashians but with
just Joe keeping up with Joe yeah you
keep up though it needs to be one of
those like game shows were like people
get voted off but just like they can't
do people voting off for people like
turning off the TV
I wholeheartedly believe you were like a
reality TV thank you all the time right
I love okay so what I do miss is like I
love eating with people so sometimes
I'll cook some [ __ ] and I'm like man
what sucks is I can't share this with
anyone so share it with us all the time
we see your [ __ ] age no but like
you're good to eat and hang out and like
like serve somebody right like I think I
enjoy that like but the thing is I
didn't I was so busy pre quarantine I
would have never cooked in the first
place yeah because I was busy out yeah
you still like live cooking sessions and
like happy will join in I would also
make it there you go oh yeah every time
I turn around you see my budget only for
the bottom half my dick is just dangling
like this the only time you see through
to the drops accident oh my god we're
gonna come up a good content day I've
been live streaming with Steve that's
been pretty fun cuz we're both I think
we both need that interaction somehow
and we've been doing like three
four-hour live streams oh damn I
wouldn't have done these things before
cuz I never stay home I jump in on the
first one and I said what's up and you
guys ignore me smells like [ __ ] you guys
hey I paid so they consume I'll have you
pay it highlights your name like 15 you
did thank you the deal just say hi [ __ ]
I didn't even see your name yeah and
then people are like Kyoto juju and I'm
like okay they'll stay what's up and
then I'm like [ __ ] they ignoring me imma
I would have said hi if I seen it like
no like people visit it in and out
I thought David's account was fake like
I thought it was someone that pretended
to be David so I was like cussing him
out the whole time no it was really
David it was really David I like I was
like [ __ ] you you're not real you
[ __ ] fake and I'm like I know David's
account it's David so comedy not being
told you he changed it I know but I
forgot it's 42 cuz our genius brain is
on there too so I should know that's
right yeah he told us he's chasing
everything a genius brain no he did and
then he turned it to David so ah yeah
cuz I thought it was genius brain and
then death well anyways so you seen
before ours do you are you ever like oh
what do I talk about now or does it end
and you're like I don't want it to end
cuz I got so much to say yeah because I
think well I'm one deprived of human
contact and it Steve is too so we just
go off and what we've been doing is um
so Steve accidentally sent out the
stream link that people can go into
instead of the youtube link so I just
started having all these random [ __ ]
trying to join our stream so I started
letting him in and they were the fans
because Steve gave out the wrong link
and that started to become like a chat
party so that was fun and I was like
dude that's another thing we can do for
JK news is we because we always talked
about bringing fans in and and just
having fun talking with them but we
didn't want to give this location are
you doing them in where you meet them at
like a public space put like a bag over
their head we might have to but now if
we do like this zoom [ __ ] we can do it
you have to be secretive you can't let
people know where you're yeah that's
true Julie is very familiar with
kidnapping people apparently yesterday
we did one where this girl was getting
harassed by a guy so I was like you know
what why don't you talk to her and see
if you got the balls to talk to her
right and then they the guy ran away but
the girl showed up and then she was like
yeah this guy that I'm kind of talking
to he's in the room too so we brought
him in finds out that she's not even
talking to him they're in a 5-year
relationship and they just recently
broke up and they just went
in like told us all of these deep doubt
like deep dark secrets and it was a
[ __ ] dope ass that's awesome there's
a license on YouTube so yeah yeah yeah
it was it was just the recent one that
we posted still have drama in your life
yeah we need Tama
so it's not drama that affects me but
it's interesting right this was better
than Netflix we saw it unfold how the
whole corner just be like hey exes hit
me up if you want to talk to your ex
online they just have that whole segment
dr. Phil the new Jenny Jones oh yeah ex
corner the ex quarter ha ha ha
now that needs to start with the C Joe
and Steve relationship therapy or
whatever I don't know I like the guys is
product where it was on sale sounds like
$500,000 and then they're like you price
it's like 20 bucks that's another thing
we're doing too cuz like going back to
like trying to find work or like I all
my brand deals are shut like day the
sponsors are like can't we hold up until
like things cool down yeah so I was like
well [ __ ] I got I want to do something
and like I'm constantly working so
steve-o and we were just live-streaming
and we're like what if we do some
educational [ __ ] but make it fun yeah I
still don't know what you guys are
selling they were pitching it they're
like we don't know just yet you know you
guys might just make us do so so
literally it's an improv show right so
everyone that pays now they can control
what we're going to do so let's say you
bought into the program right then that
means you have a voting power so like
let's say you want Casey's like teach me
how to [ __ ] like eat [ __ ] right and
then [ __ ] it Nelson's like teach me how
to like like Drive a car that's right
hand drive for some crazy [ __ ] it's a
normal car left hand drive with either
hand just fine thank you very much and
in the do use like [ __ ] it
teach me Bitcoin or whatever right so
then Holly yeah cuz it could be as
normal as like you can be the richest
one yeah learning how to eat [ __ ] is
pretty
dude if you can't forget on your own
it's not that easy Casey no everyone's a
master like you yeah I can't see ya that
Court right
well how are you gonna teach that course
specifically oh I mean it'll you're
gonna lick the camera Oh we'll find some
funny [ __ ] to do so the goal is we're
gonna teach real [ __ ] that's that's like
that that they want to learn but it's
gonna be funny as [ __ ] but it's really
informative but it's up to them to
choose the topics and we have to do it
no matter what when is it deadline I
want to join second make you guys do
[ __ ] funny [ __ ] well we're probably
gonna I don't know we're probably gonna
we'll do it like in a week or so yeah I
just I'm gonna block it off at a
thousand s people so yeah
[Music]